the breakthrough announced in a tweet
from israeli prime minister yeh lapid a
defining moment for the two states that
used to cooperate in military and other
spheres but who over ten years had
become estranged
and the turkish foreign minister malu
ciao was quick to confirm the
development
among the steps we planned to normalize
relations there was also the
reappointment of respective ambassadors
if you remember we made a statement in
the news conference we held with mr
lapid that we started work on the
appointment of ambassadors
such a positive step came from israel as
a result of these efforts and as turkey
we also decided to appoint an ambassador
to israel to tel aviv
relations between the two countries
soared after israel attacked gaza in
2008 killing more than a thousand
palestinians but it was the gaza
flotilla raid in 2010 that fully severed
ties between the two countries israeli
troops attacked the flotilla which was
carrying humanitarian aid for gaza in
international waters killing nine
turkish citizens
since then diplomatic ties have been
virtually non-existent
in one year there will be a presidential
elections here in turkey but with
inflation at more than 70 percent ankara
wants to attract investments from
regional countries there are security
challenges too in syria and the eastern
mediterranean basin turkey sees israel
as a strong player and for israel turkey
is seen as a balancing power in a region
threatened by iran
the final push to man relations started
last year
in march israeli president isaac herzog
visited turkey and met turkish president
recep tayyip erdogan two months later
turkish foreign minister joshua visited
tel aviv
the final major stepped over
normalization of relations was when
israeli prime minister yeh lapid visited
ankara in june it was during that trip
that the two sides agreed on a road map
to fully restore diplomatic ties
however turkey also made it clear that
it will not compromise when it comes to
supporting the palestinian cows
herzegovina
we have always said we will continue to
defend the rights of palestine jerusalem
and gaza and it's important that our
messages are conveyed directly at the
ambassadorial level in tel aviv
that support for palestinians remains a
sensitive issue and even with the full
restoration of diplomatic ties is likely
to remain a contentious difference
between the two countries
resource al jazeera istanbul